okay so I've been saying for more than a
year now that whatever the truth of
Donald Trump's criminality is neither
impeachment nor indictment nor removal
on the basis of the 25th amendment our
reliable means for removing the
president of the United States the most
likely and most efficient tactic to
remove Donald Trump is to vote in
November of 2020 and to have him out by
January of 2021 that remains the case in
light of what we know so far about
Robert molars report nothing surprising
whatsoever the problem is that it
appears to me that Donald Trump is very
very quickly barreling towards
re-election in 2020 it doesn't give me
any joy to say it this is not and
i-told-you-so thing in the sense that
we've been saying the power of
incumbency is important even when a when
a president has a low approval rating
remember that half the country doesn't
vote you can win theoretically with an
approval rating in the high 20s and
Donald Trump's approval rating has
consistently been in the high 30s yes
Trump goes on these embarrassing Twitter
rants indicative of total lack of self
control of mental illness of serious
personality disorders it doesn't matter
okay anyone who cares about that
behavior is already not voting for
Donald Trump and most of his base
doesn't care about that and then when
you consider that gas prices are
generally pretty low it's a silly metric
but it actually correlates to electoral
success particularly for presidential
re-elections historically even though
the economy we know isn't working for
millions and millions of people stagnant
wages although they've been trickling up
a little bit no health insurance for a
ton of people rising cost of living
massive inequality historically when the
unemployment rate is low and it's low
now when inflation is low and it's low
now incumbents get reelected regardless
of party whether or not they promise to
pay off the debt but have actually grown
it at record speed it's not a voting
issue so this is a big-picture analysis
this is not about Trump loving
authoritarian
this is not about how the white house
has been taken over by this swamp
filling nepotistic kleptocracy that
includes trump's family all those
analyses are accurate but this is the
reality that if certain economic
indicators are doing okay
short of a huge and visible economic
downturn or scandal of the type that
we've not yet seen actually damaged
Trump he's likely to be reelected there
are a couple different models that look
at this one says Trump will win with 294
electoral votes if the economy more or
less stays the way it is now others are
closer one isn't even bigger blowout
than that so the one indicator that
could actually lose Trump the election
is not about money it's not about wealth
or economics its turnout and I've been
talking about this for a while Pat the
one variable that goes beyond
unemployment and gas prices or anything
like that is turnout because if
Democrats can get even a modest boost to
turnout that could be all it takes to
removed from from office and the reason
why is that the election ultimately
comes down to the results of a few key
states a few swing states as we
typically call them even a couple of
percentage point boost to voter turnout
for Democrats over Republicans in key
states can change this from a trump
blowout to a democratic win so Pat I'm
not saying Trump is definitely getting
reelected I'm not saying anything in
particular about the Democratic
candidates here we're talking about them
separately what I am Telling You is that
the broader circumstances in which we
find ourselves
indicate that Donald Trump could well we
be barreling to a blowout reelection
here yeah I would call Donald Trump the
slight favorite at this point although
of course we don't know what the
economic indicators will be a year and a
half from now like you say
turnout is key I think back in 2016
there was a lot of apathy people thought
Hillary Clinton Donald Trump they're
both so unpopular I'm just gonna stay
home I'm gonna sit this one out
I don't think we're gonna see that same
apathy in 2020 I think people do
understand there's a significant
difference between the Democrats
and the Republicans especially a
Republican like Trump and I think people
will go to the polls because the Supreme
Court is important and immigration
policy is important and I don't think we
want to go through this national
embarrassment for another four years
well we'll see and for those who are
either hoping for or betting on some
kind of scandal at this point can you
even dream up a scandal big enough that
would actually affect Donald Trump's
base more than a by a couple of points
which still just means that's a couple
points that have to be made up by
Democratic voters on the Left the the
base doesn't care we can't wait for a
scandal we knew all along Trump's not
going to be you know perp-walked in
handcuffs by Robert Mulder it was never
going to happen
it's turnout its turnout and it's
ultimately going to come down to whether
we get the vote out and get enough
people to vote that it doesn't matter
whether Trump's base gets out or not
because we simply have a bigger bigger
turnout and more voters that's all it
comes down to an otherwise expect Donald
Trump until 2024 one of the day's
sponsors is privacy calm slash Pakman
which is a free service that I myself
use really useful in many different ways
takes just a few seconds to link your
debit card to privacy calm then you can
create virtual credit cards that are
linked directly to your bank account and
you use those virtual credit card
numbers to buy things online which
protects your actual debit card so that
it's not spread all over the internet
and one of the best things about it is
how their mobile app and browser
extensions for Chrome and Firefox make
it really easy to use let's say for
example that I'm signing up for a David
Pakman show membership in the credit
card number field I already see the
privacy com icon I just click it choose
which of my virtual credit cards I want
to use and the credit card number
expiration date and security code are
automatically entered I can put in any
zip code I want and I'm done and if you
try to use my credit card number that
you just saw on the screen it doesn't
matter because I've already deleted that
virtual card and that's the beauty of
privacy calm there are a ton of it
Vantage's - using a free service like
this for example you can sign up for as
many free trials as you want then just
delete the virtual credit card you used
and never worry about getting charged
for it it protects you from getting
hacked it protects you when companies
are hacked which happens all the time it
is all completely free all you have to
do is click the link under this video to
get started and for a limited time
they're giving everyone in our audience
$5 towards your first purchase when you
sign up using that link